es blutet drama notarzt krankenhaus und
genau das ist unsere zuschauerin
jeanette dass man aus leipzig vergangen
und sie ist zugeschaltet hallo frau
käßmann
hallo frau käßmann das sind unglaubliche
bilder die sie uns auch geschickt haben
die werden wir auch einen blenden wie
geht es ihnen heute so ganz habe ich sie
nicht verstehen aber ich vermute es geht
ihnen gut also tatsächlich lassen wir
uns noch mal erklären wie ist es zu dem
vorfall gekommen
ich bin wie jeden tag mit meinem hund
spazieren gegangen und habe dann von
beiden einer gartenfreundin mit vier
schäferhunden gesehen
wohlweislich umgetreten meinen hund aber
sie hat mich leider doch erwischt so
dass ich von hinten von den vier hunden
umgerissen wurde das heißt die leine hat
sich um eine füße gewickelt ich wurde
ungefähr zeit sein halben meter über dem
boden mitgezogen und als ich wieder
stand nach einer weile habe ich meinen
hund gesucht und gehen dann in berlin
vier schäferhunden gefunden und er ist
auch schwer verletzt worden haben die
dazu gebissen haben die sie auch
attackiert diese schäferhunde ja als
erstes habe ich gesehen dass die vier
hunde wirklich vier ecken von einem hund
in der mangel hatten so dass schon
sämtliche der mit des bundes auf dem weg
lagen also hatte am rücken und der ganze
baum richtig aufgerissen man hat gesehen
wie die hunde anheben nun richtig
gezahlt haben als ob sie jeden schritt
will zerlegen